i'm chris willis i'm with the cloud
platform team at google and today we're
going to have a conversation about
container technology in fact you might
say a grown-up conversation we've got
some leaders from the container software
industry here to share perspectives with
this starting with alex Povey who is the
CEO of core OS we also have Craig
McCluskey who leads the product
management team that works on containers
here at Google and kit Colbert who's the
CTO for the cloud native applications
effort at VMware and with that we'll get
started we have questions for all of you
so first of all why does anybody care
about container technology why are we
even having this conversation why does
it matter maybe I'll take this one
so I think about container technologies
as being important for two reasons the
first reason is is what is today and
then the second part of it is we're
going in the future and both of these
are worth discussing the first part of
it today as exemplified by docker is
that container technologies have solved
a really hard problem around the
hermetic sealing and deployment of an
application so they've taken something
that has historically been very fraught
and difficult and occasionally fails to
becoming something that's very
predictable has a great developer
experience around it and so they've
solved this hard problem in a way that's
accessible to engineers and engineers
like it for that reason the second thing
I think a lot about containers is when
where containers are going and if you
think about it containers really grew up
as a technology in the internet giants
because it's the only practical way to
accomplish internet scale computing now
as we look to the future every
enterprise is on the cusp of needing to
act as in a company as IOT and mobile
enabled workforces emerge they need
access to the capabilities that have
previously been the provenance of the
Internet giants alone and what icy
containers to you know technology is
doing is running moving the world
forwards into this cloud native
computing paradigm and letting everybody
benefit from the same paradigms of
computing that people like Google or
Facebook or Twitter or others have had
to sort of build for themselves and
pioneer themselves so if we think about
a world if you know before and after
write what is what are its container
technology replacing what would bubble
would never replace but with what are we
doing now today that we're
I'm gonna do in the future everything
running containers yeah I mean one thing
I wanted to add to Craig's point on the
previous question was that I think a lot
of times when we use the word container
we actually bring in a lot of other
concepts with them right there's one
thing around basically what container
technologies like docker have done which
is a variety like a great packaging
framework and then the docker engine
orchestration framework on the linux
host but there's a lot of other aspects
to the application and the way the
application that is produced that I
think really derives like the kind of
end and benefits that folks are looking
for so containers are absolutely
enabling and they're awesome right and
they're great but then there's questions
like the application architecture and so
wow that's breaking down these more
monolithic architected apps to be
something might call distributed or
micro services and as you do that you
enable your development teams to start
moving more independently you build more
agility into that then there's things
like continuous integration and
continuous deployment there are a whole
process around how you really optimize
and automate the software development
lifecycle so I think it's really I think
important to point out that when you say
containers a lot times people think
about this you know they kind of see all
these different pieces which each have
specific areas and names and
technologies behind them but then
there's kind of the actual container
technology that you were talking about
Craig as well so I think it's important
to kind of establish that there's many
different pieces here going on I mean
you talked about almost every part of
software development that touches on
everything it is and I think you know to
get back to Craig's point this notion
around how every company's kind of
becoming like a web scale Internet
company thinks absolutely true you know
I think was Marc Andreessen right four
or five years ago now that was saying
that you know software's eating the
world has that big op-ed in the New York
Times and his point there was that
companies are by and large becoming
software companies in the sense that
software is how they engage with their
users and is by and large how they
differentiate their products right
doesn't matter what industry you're in
you you're kind of becoming a software
company so it's one example of this
right so this company John Deere they
blog very publicly about the kind of
transformation they made so this is
again a company those tractors combines
that sort of thing
and yet the value to their customers is
no longer just the tractor that they
build it's actually the sensors they put
on the tractor the fact that beams that
up to the cloud they're this big data
analytics platform it runs in the cloud
and that information then goes back down
to the tractor so they can then optimize
and maximize the productivity of the
land and that's what they're really
producing so think about that transition
right it's a company and what John Deere
has been very vocal about is their use
of containers and continuous integration
deployment all these other things that
come together to really differentiate
them as a business in the software world
so I think that's kind of I think if we
ask the why that's the why because
that's John Deere didn't do it someone
else would come out and they make an
okay tractor but in an awesome analytics
platform and they would eventually beat
out John Deere right so I think that's
the kind of competitive environment that
is starting to . where's a competitive
weapon and this absolutely it's a huge
differentiator
so myths about containers who's got some
myths that we need to bust about
containers definitely have some myths
for it like there's a bunch of myths
rolling around right now one big one is
that containers replace virtual machines
I think so here's here's the big picture
so container has this little bit unit
yeah it does kind of resemble a virtual
machine if you like squid is the right
way Owen we're talking about containers
we're really talking about this thing
that Craig alluded to which is this way
of managing infrastructure that the
hyperscale guys have done for a while
now but hasn't been done early in
enterprise and the difference there is
with a virtual machine what you do is
you take a big server and you carve it
up into lots of little servers and you
treat them as like throwing little
servers with containers you take a set
of containers and you deploy them in you
manage them is one big machine so it
allows you to string a set of machines
as if it was one giant thing it's this
idea of managing a data center as a
computer there's one and that has a lot
of benefits around letting the software
do the optimization of you know you ttle
ization or letting it help the
operations team actually keep things up
and available and so on so if you think
about it that way a little bit bigger
picture than just that container it's
it's completely kind of completely
different one other one just call out
and let you guys go after that is around
security and so containers have gotten a
pretty bad rap for security but we have
to step back for a moment and think
about what were you doing before can
so what you're doing before containers
is you were just running a bunch of
different applications on one machine
and if any of those things got
compromised in any way the attacker now
can go get the rest of the server and
it's rather trivial from there at least
with containers you're putting up some
boundaries and walls between every
single individual application really the
only way that you could do that
previously is if you launched a full
server virtual machine for one
application which you know it sometimes
happens but isn't the like typical use
case the server infrastructure so even
today the containers have gotten a lot
of criticism for security but then you
need to just stop for a second wait a
minute before this you were just letting
everything kind of go to town but sorry
let me add two the first one I may be
kid wants to talk to the second one
there's some interesting conversation
about there I think alex is exactly
right I think the biggest mistake people
make around containers today is they
think about it the same way that they
think about that virtual machine and
there's this there's a couple of things
that are really important that that one
needs to consider the first is with
containers you're creating something
that is far more atomic and easily
scheduled able so if you think about the
way that people tend to run virtual
machines it builds something in a
virtual machine and be vertically
scalable you could add in additional
resources by creating additional
processes but eventually get to the
boundaries of your system and then the
wheels would fall off you would have to
really kind of change your sort of way
of thinking you'd have to make this big
bold transition into a distributed
system as well that was really hard so
it was easy for people to build systems
that would scale to a point it was
practically impossible for most
engineers to build systems that got
beyond that and one of the things I
think that you know we have an
opportunity to do as we move towards the
containers is to think about the atom of
deployment is being at the process level
rather than as a sort of subsystem level
and creating a very natural way to tie
these things together in a useful
fashion so they can be easily you know
stood up consumed scaled you know turned
up 10 down and by doing so producing
tremendous value for the end consumer
because you get far more efficient use
of your resources you don't have to
worry about scaling events the health of
your system is managed for you and you
get far more insight into how things are
behaving because you behind me operating
this higher abstraction I think that's
an incredibly key construct as we look
to the next and here's
and I'll say I think on that note when
people think of vm's that you know there
is there's multiple aspects to it I like
to just decompose into two simple
aspects of a VM there's kind of the
Vienna is the packaging mechanism right
that you can install on OS and but it
happened there create a VM template and
then provision that thing you know as
much as you want but there's also the VM
as the runtime vehicle and I think that
you know what we see is VM packaging was
kind of a necessity before containers
and just with a lot of traditional
applications especially more
off-the-shelf applications where you
didn't control it you didn't have
in-house development able to change it
and it was kind of the way it was and so
VM has offer great flexibility there but
as we get into the container world it
makes a lot more sense if you can to
package an application inside a
container I think our point of view of
course is that we think we can bring a
lot of the benefits of the VM runtime to
containers right in front from a runtime
scenario I think the other point I would
make just on the on the misconceptions
around containers is again this notion
that when we think of containers again
the association with that is typically
like a Google style type infrastructure
got this awesome app which is like
highly distributed and totally you know
resilient infrastructure failure and all
these great things and then people say
okay well I can take my old you know 20
year old legacy monolithic app toss that
thing and boom I'm good to go it's like
the magic pixie dust and all of a sudden
this thing is highly scalable and
resilient to hardware failure and it's
like actually no you know if the
container is very helpful but if you
know if your application is very helpful
in the sense and let me finish that very
helpful in the sense of you know being
able to reliably and quickly reinstate
that application on any infrastructure
you want but if the application is
broken doesn't scale falls over a lot
they're gonna have a broken not scalable
application that falls over a lot that
you reinstated that was sometimes faster
so I think the big thing that I always
talked to customers about is and users
about is like hey guys you not only need
to think about containers you also need
to think about application architecture
cuz that's the much harder thing to do
is how do you actually reaaargh attack
the app to take advantage of these kind
of this distributed paradigm it's not a
lift and shift your old app it's a year
old app is magical yeah and now again
that's maybe another of the
comment there because the VM enabled
that sort of lift and shift but with
containers you can do that but you don't
get all the benefits right to really
realize the full benefits you need that
sort of rethink on the architecture so
what kind of additional point to make
there's I agree with you I think there's
a big sort of cognitive shift that he's
happened but it's far less big than the
cognitive shift has ever been before if
you think about the bad old days or so
on and if either of you working so
technologies yeah
or try to deploy an Enterprise Service
bus but the process of actually getting
to the goodness of this distributed
assistance you'd have to make these huge
investments right you'd have to retrain
all your engineers around these new
patterns and you'd have to you know we
architect your systems to actually use
specific protocols and it was a disaster
because the energy curve was like the
value proposition was there was possible
to achieve these patterns of operating
previously but there was such a
cognitive hurdle to get over that was
practically impossible and so I think
one of the things that we're starting to
see now is you know doc has made it easy
to kind of encapsulate something in a
medically sealed unit modern sort of
technologies that are actually
scheduling it make it feel like it's
just you know running in a in a
reasonable ocol environment but you can
use Sdn to wire things together you can
use software-defined storage to actually
map volumes in create a natural
experience but actually start benefiting
from a lot of the values of this this
higher abstraction which is very
powerful it feels like it's the right
time well that's a really good point I
think that's an excellent point because
I think what you're kind of getting to
is this whole notion of you know the
infrastructure architecture and
application architecture stack is
evolving as well
yes whereas before you do a lot of this
stuff yourself and figure out all these
hard of distributed systems problems you
know implement your own pack so so you
know whatever it is right what we're
seeing now is lot of stuff is available
many times open source and so rather
than you figuring it out you can rely on
some other component to do it you can
focus much more quickly I think that's
your point on the business logic of
whatever the specific thing is that
you're building and not have to worry
about all like the 10,000 other kind of
problems that go along with that but you
have these libraries or frameworks that
you can use out of the box so what needs
to happen in the industry that isn't
happening now for containers really to
take hold what are the hurdles we need
to get over
right now with that it's this whole new
platform okay and I like to use the
analogy of a phone okay imagine if your
your iPhone or Android booted up and
there was no apps on it and the first
thing you had to do as a business was to
write an application to make the
platforms those revenue revolutionary
new platform paradigm shift and
everything but the very first thing you
have to do to use it is to create your
own unit of value on top of it and
that's where we're at right now we'll
stay there are all the tools are there
but the teams that are using them have
to do a lot of the heavy lifting to sort
of feel the value of it so I think as an
industry we have to mature a little bit
in terms of having solutions put
together for users that already go in
there we need to write the dialer we
need to write the camera app we need to
write the gallery app for you you know
and that kind of stuff the general
purpose things that every operations
team needs just to make the thing useful
to them is is the challenges that I
think we're getting through right now
but the base platform where it's getting
pretty good and it's exciting agree with
that I would add one thing which is this
thing is is really important is we have
to create effective standards around
some of the core pieces that everyone
wants to build on if you think about
what containers are doing is they're
creating a natural way to express a
piece of software and describe how you
want to run and creating a framework so
you can actually take that thing and run
it and we need to create a standard that
lets people really innovate and advance
the story around the packaging and
distribution of containers continuous
integration and delivery new and unique
ways to you know to take code and
actually get it into this environment
secure operating environments for these
pieces and we need to do that in a way
that fosters a whole ecosystem and to do
that you need to actually define a team
standard and then on the other side of
it you need to you know be able to
consume that and run it in a in a broad
array of technologies I mean each of us
or our vendors and have our own set of
offerings that we need to consume we
kind of nice if there was a standard
that that people could really invest in
that really decoupled the production and
the consumption of technology and that's
what I think things like OCI are
incredibly important and it's incredibly
important that OCI focus not just on
both the
open container open container initiative
thank you yeah you know focus on really
creating a clean and sort of well
adopted standard for for you know the
that separates the production
distribution of container technologies
from the runtime and consumption of it
yeah good standard standardization on
both sides of that yeah so having a
standard sort of specification so that
the people operating on the one side of
the vie to actually want to build and to
around containers can you know work to
that specification and then people on
the other side of the divide you want to
take those containers and run them and
operate them have a common ground to
meet so that the two providers aren't
trying to tool for n different providers
implementations of the specification but
it also allows each of the n provides
the specification to create unique value
and differentiate and actually opera
real innovation in that space yeah and
you know getting back to the question
around adoption and you know that the
maturity in the space so I think if you
look at what happened let's say with you
know VMware storing the virtualization
space when that took a good I don't know
let's say really starting this on the
datacenter started probably in 2000 2001
and just in the last couple of years and
we reach kind of the point where people
aren't afraid to virtualize things
anymore before there's always some kind
of concerns and the concerns vary in a
number of different ways a lot of times
there's just a question of you know can
I as an Operations Group really run this
thing in production with some sort of
assurance that it will run and you know
I can take care of problems when they
happen and so forth and so I think what
we've seen is tremendous excitement from
developers because developers get the
value proposition of containers and they
get docker and they see how it can help
them and so now I think that the
transition point is well sorry to you
know fall on Craig's point that we're
seeing tooling come out around this as
well throughout the CI CD space and now
over onto the production side I think
that's gonna be where the rubber meets
the road in terms of like as IT teams
and operations teams start to take a
look at this and say ok how do we
actually run these things in production
how do I make sure it's secure and how
do I audit that and how do I monitor and
do I need to do backups and you know all
the sort of things that they have to
think through so I think what we're
seeing is I think this actually kind of
evolve faster probably the
virtualization just because the amount
of interest that's here right now and
the amount of folks that are jumping
into the space
but at the same time I think that right
now it's very much for most of the
customers we talked to though they're
the kind of cutting-edge ones the ones
who are willing to take a bunch of this
stuff that's still kind of you know just
starting out and kind of put it together
in a way that works for them
and what you'll see happening over time
is more out-of-the-box solutions things
that just kind of work and are able to
let these IT teams take it and run so
what's happening with the cloud native
computing foundation it's seems kind of
quiet lately that's the story okay I'm
glad you asked the question so we've
been doing a lot of work to basically
put together a framework that we think
will work well for the community we're
looking to really create a foundation
that operates fairly that has a very
strong technical identity and technical
voice that welcomes a broad array of
technologies but at the same time
achieves a convergence that makes it
useful so we've been spending quite a
lot of time in a series of conversations
through the community channels to really
get the details of how to make it run
work and there's actually a lot of a lot
of effort and a lot of thought is going
into you know how do we create an
effective Oversight Committee that isn't
bound to a specific commercial interest
how do we create a group of people that
are representing the end uses so that
that voice isn't drowned out by vendors
that have a strong commercial interest
and then you know how do we create a
principled architecture that is you know
fair to everyone in the community
whether they're end-users and vendors
and really sort of bring it together so
behind the scenes we've been working
really hard to get a lot of the details
ironed out about how it's going to work
you know how things will be managed what
the governance structure is and we're
getting very close to actually being
able to make already you know sort of
strong announcement around you know
getting through contracting and actually
starting the day-to-day operations of
the foundation so things are going very
well so assuming we have a successful
standards efforts we're able to link the
development world with the runtime world
through through well Express standards
what is a thriving to an ecosystem look
like they're containers
sure so I like the standard shipping
container analogy a lot for this because
it's it's very applicable so once we
have our standard
on the unit you know the goal is not
just to have a standard it's to have
like a global economy you know that's
the point of this so by having a unit
that is a user you can package against
and know that you have a variety of
vendors that all interoperate with that
you should see a reaching rich ecosystem
of people that are competing is
competing for your business as well as
some pretty good innovations because of
that you know as if we have the bare
minimum piece of a standard that means
as vendors we all have to duke it out
and like earn your business right we
have to make our stuff faster more
secure you know more reliable and so on
so for the end-user the standards create
that and again using the analogy here
the goal is not the standard it's the
whole global economy that's created
because there's that that basic standard
in place yeah I think I think Alex you
know hit on that with this and what we
talk about when we talk with about this
with customers the word that I hear a
lot is optionality right this ability to
not get locked into something that they
can make the choices based on their
requirements they can free to change
those choices as they need to and I
think that's kind of the vision that
we're all trying to get to where and by
the way that's also a big reason for
open-source feel a lot of open source
technologies and customers wanted to
leverage those things it's again goes
back to optionality of multiple vendors
back in that open source project so I
think you know when we see the container
spaces well we don't want to become the
super fragmented area where okay so they
have to if that happens you'll start
making these crazy kind of change the
dependency decisions like okay so if
it's like this technology and I can do
that thing well this other thing not so
well if I do this one and that one works
okay and it's like no like let's make it
very simple you you you you do the
default you know standard packaging or
whatever it is and then you have choices
do I want to use this technology for
networking this one for storage just one
for scheduling this one for consensus
you know gives you options and allows
you to leverage the best to breathe
without getting locked into anything on
the vendor side it also lets you invest
in the standards you innovate on exactly
so we make our solutions better rather
having five people reinvent the wheel
six times and I think that actually that
is a key element to driving innovation I
don't extend that to other parts of the
stack as well I think it I think it
makes sense to try to create a series of
you know what you know principled
interfaces between subsystems so that
you know if you know someone has a
really killer implementation of
something they can safely invest in that
and innovate in it and actually have it
pulled through into a variety of other
areas and so I think you know really you
know pursuing that is important and I
think you know one thing I'd like to say
which is kind of stepping back a little
bit you know when I look to the future
here a lot of things are going to change
and you know people try to play their
understanding of how operations works
you know into this new world and it's
going to change we're going to create a
radical specialization of ops the number
of people you're gonna have to maintain
- you know operate a series of systems
it's going to reduce and specialized
operations functions can emerge and I
expect each of those operations
functions will have a unique set of
tools and should be safe for preppy
providers to really focus on lighting
those things up you know the container
abstraction level provides a remarkable
amount of data you could use for things
that conclusion detection if you want to
drive security it'd be wonderful if an
ecosystem could emerge around that so I
think that's likely to happen and then
the other thing I think is going to
happen is you know one of the things we
saw inside Google when we made this
transition a long time ago is this
incredible explosion in productivity it
turns out when you actually make this
transition to not having to have your
engineers spend half their life or more
actually you know trying to maintain and
operate the thing they just built but
that principled systems can run them for
them like they become radically more
productive radically more code gets
produced and you need new classes of
tools and new ways to actually you know
define policy and see what's happening
and you know track the things that are
being deployed so I think it's gonna
introduce a very substantive change in
the way that people actually build and
operate and run these these these
technologies and the actual set of tools
the suite of tools is going to evolve in
new and interesting ways so what's the
what's the pre fry what's the pre-flight
checklist when we look at at some point
this is going to become to Canadia
technology's gonna become the default
packaging mechanism the default way we
develop software
what's the pre-flight pre-flight
checklist for how that happens when do
we know that we're there well that one I
I think so it's really about the user
and when the user is able to package
their application once sign it which
means it to them saying this is my
package and then run it across a variety
of vendors they can choose Google
container engine they can choose the
VMware products they can choose tectonic
from core OS like these different things
or any other vendor that wants to
interoperate with that standard but the
user can take that unit they can say
this is mine and then they can run it in
their own you know as in the place of
their choosing I think that's what we've
done it we actually have
interoperability and standardization and
choice for users and I think it's gonna
take the the classic sort of adoption
curve right we're gonna have some people
on the leading edge who are willing to
like roll up their sleeves and do the
extra work and sort through the myriad
number of options and just make it work
right and deal with some of the issues
of the changes and so forth it happened
down the road but I think we're
definitely hit an inflection point where
it is kind of ready for mass market I
think that's sort of the point that alex
is making is that there's gonna be a
point at which this stuff works well
enough out of the box the early adopters
have figured out a lot of the hard
problems around operationalizing these
things in production it's not some of
the other issues there and then you know
and we're always trying to do the cool
thing about this the container space is
that it really is a community if you go
to any of like the meetups or the
conferences you see a lot of people
sharing their experiences like here's
you know you know I might add a company
I took this thing we started running and
here's all the problems I hit and here's
how to avoid those in the future so as
we collect that sort of knowledge as an
industry and it's a community it will
help everyone who's new to the community
even go faster yeah I agree with that I
think every customer is going to be
different we already have a lot of
customers that are you know they roll
out these amazing statistics around you
know how how it's changed the way that
they take the technology to production
and they're able to go from you know one
rollout every two weeks to multiple
rollouts
a day that their operations are sort of
going down so for a lot of the neat the
for dating people it's been ready for
quite a while and they're already
benefited benefiting from that at the
far end of the spectrum a lot of you
know folks need developer training to
actually become familiar with the tools
they need their favorite systems
integrator to actually develop a
practice around this and to actually you
know fully inculcate in and acquire a
staff they can actually support their
needs and so it's it's gonna is in a
trickle through technology exactly as
VMS doing right like you think about
that that that vm adoption cycle they
took that took
eight years or however long to really
become prevalent I think we probably go
quicker because you know there's a two
tickets already point there's a lot of
interest around it but I think every
customer will make their decision based
on their specific needs around you know
completeness of tooling willing to no
way miss to engage in open source and
actually participate in the evolution of
the open source technology you know
they're their vendor providing them a
comprehensive suite of tools that they
need their systems integration partner
is actually being there to help them you
know through some of the transition
processes so I don't think it's a one
you know one phase answer but it's going
a lot faster than I expected
it is what I would say so with that I
think we've had a good grown up
conversation about containers no chairs
were thrown nobody stopped off the set
good success success so thank you all
for joining us today and thank you for
watching as I think you can hear this is
this is the the coming framework for how
we will write and run software so our
encouragement to you is to go out and
learn about it and there are lots of
resources from all three of these
vendors about to Canadia technology so
go go try it out go work with it thanks
so much for joining us